morning welcome to our Oscar wrap-up
it's so early it's so early in the
morning after watching this so the Oscar
nominations were just released and we're
gonna discuss some of the surprises some
of the snubs and some of the highlights
so let's dive right in
okay that's for most I think that's the
category everybody cares mo nominees for
Best Picture are American hustle
captain Phillips Dallas buyers club
gravity her Nebraska Philomena 12 years
of slave and the wolf of Wall Street so
there are there definitely some snubs
and I would say in regards to inside
Llewyn Davis which is really only
nominated for I think don't truck right
kept for sound mixing do some and
cinematographer chance in the car with
someone just a meeting it's got one
inside Llewyn Davis got as many
nominations as The Lone Ranger which is
a little troubling and this is got as
many nominations as bad grandpa jackass
wasn't bad grandpa which only we've got
one nomination for makeup and hair Neely
well deserved
it really earned that nomination so
there are some snubs I want to actually
mention not because I thought it was a
great movie but Lee Daniels the butler
which was kind of one of those about one
of those prototypical like oh this is a
movie that's gonna win it early but it
not even making the accepts and no
nominations at all the other snub I
would say is the absence of blackfish
from documentary features right the two
frontrunners though would be gravity and
American hustle which both got ten on
the page which it's funny because I
think they're both really really really
strong films they obviously come at you
know you know the the cinema dance from
different angles of the awards that be
given American hustle swept it got every
actor category right and grabbing all of
you yeah between the two of them they
pretty much overlaid all of the
categories yeah because gravity is a
one-man show yeah one-woman show the one
thing I will say that I think is really
cool is Spike Jonze is nominated for
three different categories right Harry
surprise right in the rec room that's no
actually for category oh he was a
producer on her too so writing directing
best picture and original song very odd
I mean that's a that might be a
combination that there were seen before
so let's talk about an animated feature
for a second it's notable that there's
an open ovation of the year where I
quite like monsters University myself
let's talk about what you think will win
the most awards obviously American
hustle has it working whistling gravity
has the best right I mean like they have
this right covered by oh I think that
gravity will end up taking more Awards
home simply because of that fact yeah
and the Technic technically the film is
flawless yeah so Leonardo DiCaprio gets
another Academy Award nomination and
John and Jonah Hill gets important a
little surprise no I was I was
definitely a little surprised but his
performance is incredible now do you
think Leo has any chance whatsoever
honestly I feel like the I was reading
something online the popular consensus
seems to be that like it's easy when
you've got a really older actor like
Bruce Dern who definitely deserves to be
nominated running against a younger guy
who also definitely deserves to be
nominated that the the popular opinion
can sort of turn to well I don't know
how many more movies Bruce Dern is gonna
do but Leo will be around forever yeah I
need to give him this one it's a really
strong category because maybe also have
a gia for right I think I think Dallas
buyers club has it in the bag as the
Golden Gloves kind of show the side for
both acting and I think we're not
against support and like you're saying
Wolf of Wall Street is just way too
controversial right now to possibly win
any of them which is which it shouldn't
be I know but it is that's just the way
it is that's that's the world we live in
you know no nomination for blackfish and
Wolf of Wall Street is commercial
wrapping up do you guys foresee any big
surprises you mean like what do you what
are you looking for Jim if we for saw
them they wouldn't be I know I'm saying
like are is there any category you're
watching more closely well the directors
race is gonna be pretty interesting to
me
I mean Kuran obviously won the Golden
Globe for it I think Steve McQueen
absolutely deserves it this year then
again David O'Russell I think American
hustle is gonna win the most awards this
year
interests gotta see if he finally you
and I could see that having sort of a
rolling motion to it like you could be
condemned in that it's a very well
directed movie I'm reading I'm reading
for gravity full disclosure okay good so
we'll see come on Sunday but again ii
yes it is vain gravity does not have
going for it is that if you didn't see
it in theaters you're not gonna be so
blown away by a screener that you vote
for it but you know what they're
bringing it back to theaters this week
so go check out gravity no bias them
could be voters watching probably not so
anyway we're gonna be posting a full
video with all the nominations or you
can get caught up with clips and
trailers and just sort of brush up on
your your knowledge of all these great
films that were nominated for oscars and
we'll be back later i'm sure during the
course of the race to put money on it
publicly and really put our reputations
online absolutely
yeah it's we'll come up with some
specific numbers and we'll be back yeah
so for movie clips I'm Jimmy I'm Sam and
I'm Jess thanks for watching